one one positive thing that i think
changed about single note since i've
been back is uh ev ever since ever since
the pandemic uh a lot of a lot of big
establishments now have made it possible
for you to just order your food via qr
codes oh yeah that was yeah yeah and i
was like right we're getting to the
japanese way of things now yeah less
human interaction oh brilliant although
i love it i was at nando's as you know i
had i had to pause there just for
dramatic yeah yeah i was in their nose
and i was i was trying to order my meal
and i was in a kind of a rush as well
yeah so i didn't have much time and i
thought oh it'll be easier on the app
turns out like the the this uh specific
nando's restaurant just didn't have good
cell phone service
and they didn't have free wi-fi so i was
like fighting for my life trying to
order this [ __ ] thing and every
single time i got to one webpage it just
could not get to the next one
it was like i had to keep resetting it's
about i spent about 20 minutes trying to
order this meal but i only had 10
minutes to eat yeah and then eventually
went up to the counter and i was like
give me this and they got my [ __ ]
order wrong
you just couldn't get a dog i was like i
was like oh my god man i'm fighting out
here just to get some nando
and it was terrible i mean it was it
didn't taste good either really the
specific nando's did not taste good and
i was like i thought you ordered
i ordered a butterfly chicken burger
you mean the chicken breast burger yeah
yeah chicken breasts
[Laughter]
just
i i had great nando's when i was done i
[ __ ] missed that the chips were kind
of [ __ ] the coleslaw was not as good as
i remembered i don't know it was uh i
don't know if my taste of chicken maybe
nando's isn't just as good as europe
maybe that nando specifically i need to
try more
because i had kfc and that was fantastic
i had uk kfc was so good uk kfc was good
i tell i'll tell you the second biggest
thing i noticed which was i've really
really missed japanese food service you
know it's yeah
so many times i'd go to restaurants and
like half the tables still had the [ __ ]
from the previous customers on it yeah
and i was like oh
yeah that just like isn't a thing in
japan like that shit's gone immediately
yeah oh yeah they won't even let you in
the restaurant i mean sometimes they'll
take the plate away while you're still
at the table yeah yeah yeah
yeah cause like i think you know
be after after being there for like two
weeks or something you you've had like
all the food that you missed from being
in japan and after that you go back to
your usual eating routine and then
you're just like man like you forget how
good japanese food is and just like
japanese restaurants in general because
like you order anything here even if
it's of ubereats or you go to a random
restaurant and it is it is just like
really good food standards and i just i
just forgotten
how many british establishments were
just really really [ __ ] mediocre
right and
like after you
after like the novelty wears out of yes
i'm having all these things that i've
missed being out of being out of the uk
after that wears off you're like
damn japanese food is just better
it is just so so much better
and uh yeah i've really felt that in my
last week in the uk where i just like i
just missed having good food on the
daily i don't know do you have any
japanese food while you're around no no
i didn't have any japanese some food
some of my friends wanted to and i
looked at them like no
they're not having japanese food it's
like the first time i went to la and
they took me to little tokyo
i came from
[Applause]
yeah cause like what i didn't understand
because i just realized this is you know
the uk is also island nation like japan
but japanese japan has really spoiled me
with good seafood yeah and just you know
fresh seafood that you can find yeah i
tried everywhere basically and just like
getting good seafood in the uk is so
[ __ ] difficult and i don't know why
it is because we're an island nation
that is smaller than japan you know
you know our coastline should be easier
to get to why why is it so hard to find
concentrate yeah yeah yeah why is it so
hard to find good seafood oh that is not
just like fish and chips you know yeah
yeah i did have a good lobster actually
did you yeah that was good but how much
did you pay for it you don't want to
know yeah
that's the thing right it's like it's
probably like if you want good food you
probably have to pay arduous amounts of
money you you do you
it was like a seafood pasta yeah and i
was really craving lobster because i was
like i didn't really get lobster in
japan and i really wanted like a creamy
do we get lobster in the uk uh yes
if you can pay for it it's quite
expensive okay look for like
not frozen canned stuff
yeah and it was really good and it was
it was probably the most i depend on a
single dish in the uk and i i was it was
something ridiculous like 30 40 or
something
but man was the lobster good it was so
worth it
yeah every once in a while having like a
something like that like treating
yourself to something kind of that
expensive is very nice but yeah
definitely something i felt so guilty
for when i was looked at the bill i'm
like i literally had a pastor
i'm like filing a mortgage i'm like
holy [ __ ]
yeah i do something similar in hawaii i
had i had a 55 dollar possibility it was
like
once in a while once in a while
once in a while you've got to treat
yourself
but it was again it was another seafood
pasta i don't know what it is about
seafood pasta but like there was so it
was like the entire cast of the little
mermaid on this [ __ ] pastel like
there was so much seafood on it yeah and
i was like okay i now i can see why also
55. i'll never do that again yeah i
don't know how australia is but i
noticed that the fancy restaurants in
japan are cheaper than the fancy
restaurants in the uk oh yeah yeah by
far by a lot by far i would go to
restaurant because in japan right you
can go to a restaurant and you can you
can buy a bottle of wine and it's yeah
even though it's it's obviously more
expensive that would be buying at
wholesale it's still not that big bad
like you can if we went out together we
could split a bottle of wine and it
comes to like 20 bucks each right for
like
maybe
i i noticed wine in the uk was way
cheaper
some place i went to like the the lowest
price bottle was like 150 and i was like
i want wine what kind of bougie ass
place are you getting not even not even
like not even like that bougie places
like these were like but the wine was
bougie
i think i don't know i don't know maybe
[ __ ] me for trying to eat good no
because i remember like i remember going
to like tesco's and co-op to buy like
some wine and i recognized some of the
wine that was available over there
premium wines here in japan that is like
20 bucks plus
like a five
that's just because japan isn't really a
wine drink no that's that's exactly it
and for the most part when i noticed
wines that were available you can get
wines for like a much cheaper price
because if you're drinking wine in japan
you you eating good you know you drink
you drink you're drinking it as well
this is the hard part i wanted to have
the good the the wine that was way
cheaper and nice but i also wanted to
drink all the beer so i had to like it
was very hard you can you can't do both
you can't mix and match otherwise you
end up in uh you're gonna be in a coma
the next year
i had a drink the next day so i want to
make sure that i was in peak condition
at all times that was the biggest thing
that i i forgot about which was
tactically choosing how much you drink
so you can survive and drink the next
day as well
we sound like such alcohol
i miss having like nice i you can get
ipas and stuff like that in japan but
like i love like the craft beer in the
uk it's really nice i miss having good
ciders
the biggest thing yeah like bloggers
i don't know i just missed that so i
drank a lot i had tesco meal deal as
well
how was it was it good it was amazing
i was like all of this for
pounds after having his lobster pasta
let's get out of here three
yeah it goes straight to tesco's you
know i bought that lobster pasta for
like thirty forty dollars i don't know
how much it was and it still didn't make
me as happy as that three pound meal
deal
and it was better it was honestly part
of it tasted better i was like oh my god
i get an innocent smoothie it's like
three pound smoothie in this three pound
meal deal they're practically giving it
away i was i was happy going back to
nando's that was like the biggest i'm
home now i i am now home
i had subway as well that was nice oh
subway i've got i've forgotten how good
subway was outside of japan because
subway in japan if you guys don't know
you can't toast the sandwich
you can't custom you can't pick your
bread no
i mean there's like there's like it's
two choices of bread i think what the
[ __ ] is the point if you can't pick your
bread and choose to toast it like i just
i was so shocked when you couldn't toast
your sandwich in japan yeah yeah you
what
that's like the best part of any i don't
even like subway that much that's
literally the drawing point off yeah
because i don't even like it like uber
each subway here and sometimes when
these two don't want to choose they
order a subway and i'm just like no if
i'm not having my subway toasted it is
not a subway yeah yeah i had a lot of
fast food a lot of fast food yeah and i
i'm surprised i'm not obese by the time
i came back with the amount i drank and
ate every time i saw you in the holiday
i think you had a bag of crisps
like i went to town on christmas i think
you were like more crisp than man i was
there was like one day where like we
were hanging out and there was just like
no food in this this like airbnb
but there was like family packs of
crisps so i'd eat like 20 packs of
christmas i think your dinner that day
was like a hot dog and like five packs
of doritos it wasn't five yeah it was
like
i almost said chips as well which is why
i like i pause i was like wait that's
not sorry sorry i'm i'm used to saying
it for the americans yeah the chips the
americans watching but yeah no it was
fun i i had a great time i got to see
all the friends i wanted to see and yeah
that's good yeah a lot of things really
worked out nicely because i was asking
people like last minute to hang out and
luckily everyone was able to yeah yeah i
think like i i had enough rest days in
there well towards the end because
michael my body was just like i i i need
to like not touch alcohol for like a
month after this
and which is great because we've had
quarantine since then